when it comes to certain things glass
can really get in the way take for
instance typing sure i've gotten better
over the years but i can only type
nearly 50 words per minute on these flat
software keys while i can type in double
time on one of these
now microsoft has fully embraced the
marriage between tablet and keyboard and
the surface type cover is the gold
standard of tablet keyboards but those
of us with android tablets and ipads are
still looking for as satisfying an
experience that's why i've been testing
over 15 of these different tablet
keyboards measuring everything from lap
usability to key spacing to figure out
where your fingers will be the happiest
the first option is to get a keyboard
that doubles as a cover now many android
tablet makers make their own keyboard
covers but apple
still doesn't instead dozens of
companies are trying to make up for that
seriously it's getting a little out of
hand belkin logitech even zag make at
least three keyboard covers for the ipad
out of all of them i like the zagfolio
the best it has decent sized keys with a
blue backlighting for working in the
dark and the pro version even lets you
change the background to one of 14
colors in case you happen to find
yourself working in
the disco
but i like the folio better because it
has a hinge so you can adjust the ipad
angle just like a laptop the downside
it's chunkier than others like
logitech's ultra thin cover but the best
way to turn your ipad into a laptop is
with a case called the bridge air it's
what i imagine apple's case would look
like but it costs a hundred and seventy
dollars which again is what i expect
apples would cost
it has comfortable backlit keys an
aluminum panel that's incredibly sturdy
for typing even when your legs are
crossed but it weighs more than the ipad
air 2 itself i also tested a much
cheaper model but while the 38 new trent
case has an awesome hinge the chunky
keyboard felt terrible
that's why you may just want to get a
mobile bluetooth keyboard that you can
toss in a bag instead and the good news
is they work with both the ipad and
android tablets
microsoft's 80 universal mobile keyboard
props up most tablets nicely and the
panel feels really solid under your
fingertips if you already have a tablet
stand amazon's 60 dollar fire keyboard
is incredibly thin and the keys are nice
and wide
the last thing you might want to
consider is a slightly less mobile
keyboard which will increase your typing
comfort and make you feel like you're
working at a desktop
instead of apple's own 69 dollar
wireless keyboard or belkin's plug-in
version that looks and sounds like it's
from 1985
i'd go with the 50 logitech k480 or a
cheaper bluetooth option like this 20
anchor there's still no perfect keyboard
for the ipad or android tablets or at
least nothing that compares to the
surface's ease of use and design but all
the keyboards i've shown you today
definitely be tapping away against this
can someone coming out of here
anybody